une production du studio sf bio sans
filtre le podcast où on parle ce qu'on
veut avec nos invités d'assists super
content que moi de bons plans à l'eau
cette semaine très fier de présenter le
podcast avec ma propre compagnie vegan
maipo plate
en fait on a fait une bûche de noël avec
ma blonde qui est 100% vegan donc la
bûche est ici choco noisette la boîte on
est super content il ya notre belle
titre face à bordeaux si ça se retrouve
dans tous les lieux qui ont accepté de
commander notre buch
donc si vous avez dans votre jeu europe
ne touchez pas là
ah les chicanes et le gérant de la
pâtisserie puis je me suis dit que
j'allais amené la bouche pour que la
fermeture d'hommes en exclusivité de
mélo commencer je peux pas attendre
c'est vraiment bon pour ouvrir c'est
vraiment une bonne bûche sus époque
c'est vegan temps aucune des ces
vraiment même que je dirais que c'est
une excellente bûche pour un excédent de
buch le végal nous peuvent également en
plus et vegan donc c'est mieux y est
vrai que si vous êtes vegan si vous
voulez réduire votre consommation de
produits laitiers puis duff si vous
voulez juste - encourager l'industrie
d'élevage d'animaux
si vous avez des intolérances aux
produits laitiers
c'est vraiment un esprit combatif
j'allais dire un autre mot c'est
vraiment une belle alternative pis puis
c'est en quantité limitée dans les iga
up participant donc dirigé vous de ce
pas pour faire des réserves pour le
temps des fêtes parce que j'ai pas
l'impression qu'ils vont en rester
longtemps dans les congélateurs à toi
ici arrêtera pas l'auteur non ici en
restera pas longtemps à la bûche hf déjà
c'est bon yes facaci non maintenant on a
un autre annonce aujourd'hui soit exact
le patriote l'a pas trompé jones --le à
platon sur laquelle pouvez vous
encourager dans une coupe de pièces par
mois
on va un peu modifié la formule vous
avez différents paliers on va mettre
maintenant un seul palier à trop dollars
on va arrêter de faire des on avait des
podcasts avec des invités spéciaux de
nos amis de ce c d'ici à coordonner
souvent fait constitue un volcan des
podcasts moby ph avec et vos questions
puis j'ai eu des conversations que nous
avons eues goût de jazz et puis on va
mettre les pas de casque on contourne
vraiment plus d' avance comme le moment
où on se parle on n'avait pas de casque
on est déjà tournée qui sont déjà sur
piquionne on ne raconte bruno fréthun et
alice morel-michaud puis on veut
toujours les maîtres bine bine avance
enfin que pour avoir toutes les
exclusivités de
de tous ceux c'est super junkie ça se
passe mais surtout c'est la meilleure
manière de nous encourager en donnant
trois dollars par mois autour de l'art
pour tout le monde
une autre a fait une grosse différence
pour nous ça nous permet de continuer à
faire ce beau contenu que vous adorez y
est ce exact
sinon c'est m cette semaine on a reçu
l'humoriste guillaume wagner un
humoriste un des plus des plus connus au
québec je dirais on a vraiment fait
longtemps qu'ils aient la bonne humeur
est ce qu'on est allé voir mots de ph et
nous inviter à son spectacle on n'ose
pas rêver ce vraiment bon un humour
parfois souvent un peu cinglé lettre
très critique l'autre ricky simms a
brassé la cage des gens et du système un
peu punk dans son attitude
guillaume wagner qui est un gars super
intéressant super intelligent j'espère
curieux qui est lui-même son propre case
le regarder se met pas trop douter quand
on découvre sans filtre d'abord chez les
dogues
il faisait pas beaucoup de casse puis ça
a parfois quand vous recevez un collègue
que les podcasteurs sur notre propre
piste est ce pas intéressant de parler
de toutes ces beaux sujets là qu'on le
discute avec lui alors enfin s puis un
enfant comme toujours laissé des
commentaires laissés en reading si vous
écoutez ça en audio seulement laisser
participer à discussion on aime
sous-entendent on aime ce vous lire on
aime sans interagir aussi avec vous
abonnez vous à toutes nos chaînes
partager la bonne nouvelle pour la
conversation se rendent dans le plus
d'oreilles possible acheté début je
gagne mes places disponibles en
quantités limitées dans les gérer je le
répète encore parce que tu as quand même
c'est le fun de parler de sa propre
affaire c'est ma propre affaire fait qu
à l'éthique est seul dans les yeux puis
sinon mon podcast bons échos
[Musique]
guillaume wagner salut les gars mais
robin merci d'être là bas un plaisir
d'être là un plaisir de voir votre
superbe au studio ce budget sérieusement
c'est très pro merci coup le premier
collègues et podcasts en vacances le 1er
- c'est le ba ba de la présente tout a
commencé presque en même temps que je
suis pas dans ça fait c'est vrai c'est
vrai qu'en même temps quand même quand
tu es dans l'engrenage losc comme ça
sans chasse aux pieds
c'est beaucoup de travail de plus de 3
grâce à l'ewi tenant des thèses dit est
ce que tu t'es dit nous on us nous c'est
cinq ans teddy on se dit un parchemin
depuis on déroge jamais ça va être chaud
comme toute attitude ça ou ça peut être
plus long chez moi j'ai le même gérant
mike bray fake
puis là il me dit ouais non une fois par
semaine c'est important pour une commune
comme noter que je comme cette tant que
seule la communauté hip hop y est c'est
important pour les autres même s'ils
n'ont fait quoi j'ai jamais dérogé je
pense prête une semaine ou plus que ça
ouais mais c'est ça justement c'est de
la dure il faut ça fait pas vraiment
encore avec à qui jean tp 4 l'appui bref
c'est quand même une logistique qui est
assez complexe mais qui est très le fun
noir
vraiment c'est à travers les choses
c'est quand même la recherche sur soi
les cyclistes livré au complet le juge
j'ai pas le temps je lis en diagana
leurs voeux j'écoutais le dernier avec
son nom m'échappe l'astronome way
sébastien gauthier c'est vraiment bon
mais vraiment ce que je lis je les
rencontre ait lieu de mon ami jusqu'à la
70e puis je l'écoutais qui vision
artistique en même temps de l'astronomie
extrait ça vraiment intéressant qui lui
est d'ailleurs vu partir un podcast fixé
la veille non mais pourquoi ça va
j'avais pas que tchité comme mais sais
tu peux t'en partir mais je pense pas
moins le meilleur la pop star était là
dedans mais ça explose du podcast notre
mauvaise série
c'est ben en fait c'est littéralement
comme 4 à 4 5 1 de retard sur remettons
la culture aux états unis huawei cambrai
les français le pensent qu'elle offre et
l'homme et la demande n'est pas encore
au niveau de l'offre mettons le cap à ce
que les gens croient que je crois pas
que les gens qui commencent à 6 je sais
que si c'est important mais tant de
fureur sur youtube par exemple parce que
parce que les gens consomment ce c'est
au québec les gens consomment youtube
mais consomme pas encore nécessairement
balade août
maintenant je suis d'accord avec toi +
moi j'ai des amis proches le mais proche
des des bonnes connaissances in the
heights vous appartient pas de casse
comme ça ça fait un excès pata pata
convenu comme le staff a quand même sa
corniche et maintenant mais je pense que
ça va ça va se développer de plus en
plus loin j'avais j'avais un meeting
avec un gain de cube radio qui s'occupe
de la division pas de case une radio qui
disait que mais dont l'application
balade de pousser vraiment pas les
podcasts francophone
quand même le monde au québec ont des
reçoivent des ddd production des
suggestions qui sont anglophones
donc si on a des bonnes cases
francophones mais quinze autres c'est
comme un pôle canada il sent qu'il soit
par itunes seulement inquiétudes
poussent moins mais j'avoue moi avec le
même aussi dangereuse l'application le
sait ce que je vois pas ce que c'est ça
aussi c'est ça ouais mais sûrement
faudrait mais c'est bon ce que vous
faites justement là-dessus comme
centralisée sappi ses fans une petite
machine qui qui propulse le plus en
podcast school sa joie on avait besoin
de ça en fait jouer parce que ça fait
longtemps que ça se parlaient en fer
doivent être les premiers à le fois
finalement c'est chez les humoristes
parlait beaucoup de ce juste pas abouti
ouais quoi les studios pour la femme -
là lexus bordel mais c'est comme ça
c'est ben mustapha ça pas trop ce qu'ils
vont faire avec ça on fait beaucoup avec
soin mais ils font des tests en ce
moment puisqu'ils savent pas trop ce
qu'ils s'en vont avec ça mais ils l'ont
pas fait pour rien c'est exact c'est
tellement ça peut pas être ça peut pas
des grosses entreprises qui prennent sur
cette place là parce que parce que par
définition il pourrait pas faire des
podcasts qui intéresserait
nécessairement tout le monde sait le
podcast gay comme une forme yves
irrévérencieuse qui est way qui doit pas
jeter dans des moules qui sont
restreints ce soit organique
moi mon papier c'est 100 % des intérêts
personnels loin s'il n'y a pas de ligne
directrice le jeu gers une artiste
récemment ça va sortir bientôt une
artiste visuel s'appelle miss me viens à
me demander c'est quoi la ligne expliqué
c'est quelqu'un qui écoute pas dévoilé
ses serments je me laissais - le kg un
vêtement tout l'argent là c'est tout une
belle salle commençait c'est pourquoi
dans ce cas
ouais mais tu en bouclant bocage
c'est ça parle de quoi va pas de casque
de tout de tout mais c'est ça qui est
fascinante et moi je disais j'ai invité
des sportifs des artistes un artiste
visuel des intellectuels des philosophes
des historiens mais met le maire de
coarraze et le moche d'intéresser
jusqu'au lieu demain mais oui c'est ce
qui pique en même temps moi c'est ce que
je remarque le plus c'est vraiment
comment on parle avec nadeau dubois se
voit une formation continue
- cc comme à chaque semaine tu apprends
des nouvelles affaires qui ne veut pas
du tout informés sur la personne et tu
vas recevoir fait que tu apprends les
nouveaux trucs tu fais des choses que
c'est comme ça elle vaut son spectacle
et tout ce que je savais qu'on allait
dans ce ton spectacle on est allé
volontiers parlement que je serais allée
toute façon mais comme ça te fait faire
des trucs puis réfléchir sur des choses
pour un truc pour en parler dit d'accord
sans conserver si le petit je lis des
livres j'aurais po lu je suis content de
lire le diplôme nécessaire au jeu mais
font pleuvoir des affaires puis - c'est
vraiment c'est trippant le17 fort ça te
garder allumée et pillé et brûlé c est
curieux et ce qui est probablement la
fin le plus important de ma vie je
trouve et puis nancy - d'où la
popularité des podcasts en ce moment les
gens qui sont intéressés pierre - et on
est en vie dont ils ont envie
d'apprendre le thé les les personnes les
plus intelligentes ma parcelle les plus
intelligentes que j'ai vue dans ma vie
que j'ai croisés c'est des gens qui
quand qui posait une question tu avais
l'impression qu'ils étaient réellement
dans la réponse c'est pas tout le monde
qui est là qu est la capacité ou qui que
l'intérêt d'écouter réellement la
réponse mais maintenant je dois donner
un exemple etienne la vallée sein de nos
amis avec qui on faisait la natation
puis lui ce n'est personne les plus
allumés que j'ai rencontré de ma vie
piquant qui posait une question
peu importe c'est quoi la maison mois
par rapport à quand j'écrivais des
délais pour enfin posé une question sur
lecture jeunesse le même si ses bases et
urologue est à des années lumière de sa
formation le may écouter ce que je
disais puis il s'intéresse réellement à
ce que j'avais à dire ouais comme ça
après celui cette nouvelle connaissance
lors qu'ils viennent d'assimiler venant
de quelqu'un qui était dans un milieu
complètement moi je pense est une des
qualités du podcast en fait c'est que
il n'y a pas de mensonge là dedans puis
je m'explique ce que je trouve ce sont
les entrevues moi j'en ai fait beaucoup
le style aussi ça fait très chaud les
gens n'aient jamais j'en ai donné sopi
souvent tu le sais ils attisent
l'intérêt d'aucune des cuites c'est beau
un peu tu as des papiers en avant des
questions petite soeur mais tu fais
semblant que tu sais si c'est un
mensonge lettres là on est en train de
mentir à tout le monde comme donc toi tu
fais simple c'est quand même moins faut
que ça soit 500 sur les subventions de
la qualité du botia c'est comme
naissance à ma fille je ne sais pas de
quoi tu parles aussi j'ai pas lu ton
affaire où est l'erreur je veux je veux
je vous le dis je vais être sincère et
puis ça se ressent je pense que
chaleureuse plus main puis je suis
entrevue questions réponses ils posent
des questions japon
kadhafi de parler pour la prochaine
question bajrami votre coupé comme une
conversation
ouais ouais cauchemar at elle j'avais
donné une entrevue le bon ce sera pas un
instrument un nom super je peux le
battre et on s'en fout c'était un des
pays écoutait jamais les réponses mais
jamais je m'appelle une fois j'arrête
avec ce qu'on sait maintenant moins six
mois de juin mais kalou un narcissique
la mer mais je me rappelle une fois j'ai
donné entrevue avec lui je suis allé
dans le diplôme quand même je vais te
l'avait révélé quelque chose n'avait
jamais révélé quelque chose de très
personnel
j'avais une force dont un peu dépressive
après mon premier spectacle je dise quoi
que je dise lui bandent sur un autre
affaire le met complètement showbiz 0
j'aurais puis dire j'ai envie de me
suicider reygadas ok maintenant on va
jouer au jeu de gagne ça c'est la partie
du show biz c'est une extrême la
messénie à une partie du show biz
l'acquis et qui est moins intéressante
je pense pour nous et pour les
générations on trouve simplement prévu
avec jean philippe brothier une fois
piégeux pastèque 30/2 bombardier puis
pose une question plaît à la part la
part et enfin ta question à fait le
genre qu'est ce t'en penses tu pas trop
les faits owen j'écoutais pas
c'est mort ben moi non plus je n'aurais
pas été donné ce mardi matin
justement le rôle c'est d'en faire de
même c'est quand il faut que je pense au
prochain segment faut que je pense au
times annoncé la levée de ce genre il
leur faut que c'est faux que sa robe en
tant que simple auto union à fanta
peut-être plutôt denise bombardier
t'explique de couette
c'est beaucoup de pression c'est une
grosse machine si je disais ça a ses
défauts on a parlé des défauts mais wes
vous soir d un maudit le c'est quelque
chose que je pourrais pas passer c'est
impressionnant dit anton ohno reçus nous
ne collait aux élèves qui vacille
ashtiani météo des plus en direct puis
ce même soir et week-end qui est
excellent c'est comme même été
impeccable comme il ya du monde qui
dérape de tous les côtés autour de toi
tu es capable de jasper flou pflug au
détail mais comme tout le temps le faire
dans avec la grippe et câbles vraiment
rigolo c'est csu pas fascinant de voir
ces mécanismes lot une fois l'on fait du
podcast on s'entend que pas d'animation
nécessaire voilée c'est juste une
conversation mais une fois que tu
réalises tout ce qui peut se passer dans
une discussion comme ça puis avec dédé
des temps restreint ses chapeaux mais je
peux comprendre effectivement que ça
intéresse un petit peu moins un format
aussi colorés oui et non aujourd'hui
avec avec toutes les parce qu'on en a
tellement
c'est moyen-moyen ci-dessous - c'est ça
la force de la force de michael de son
pas de casque est attendu mondial d
afrique en titre
c'est un publicité les gens et que c'est
parce que moi je les fait souvent puis
il ya comme une espèce de
il ya une atmosphère inspirée de
pression c'est normal et je pense que
toutes les fois où j'ai fait un paquet à
ce jeu sorti je me suis dit comme ça
qu'est sécher pourquoi j'ai une autre
averse
non tout le temps tout le sud réussit à
sortir sur mac comme quoi mais
conviviale que s'est dit le territoire
récemment très récemment
ça va sortir le cameroun mais je l'avais
un peu gelé fait je pense que pendant 10
minutes j ai dit comme fo qu'invite éric
lapointe c'est sûr que les s bannalec
je sais pas mais non jamais après la
controverse de martin match par son
jeune âge j'en ai pas mal je vais je
n'avais peut-être un peu non derrière
j'ai révélé récemment qu'une affaire
très privé le par rapport à sophie
durocher j'ai révélé sa son podcast j'ai
commencé peut-être mais ouais ça saporta
seulement je suis trop chez les 80
packard de deux ans acquiesce et roule
encore tout chaud par rapport à elle va
lui coûter jusqu'à qui garde tout ce qui
est je pense que d'un point de vue tant
que tu portes définitivement une
meilleure opinion de ce que nous
souhaitons c'est ce qui est une espèce
de kant et quand et humoristes invités
le un espèce de david allées dallées
punch et il ya seulement c'est un genre
comme un instit tremplin site est drôle
c'est un pack 15 de punch le trackpoint
chloé c'est fait pour ça puis ça a ses
qualités mais à ses défauts aussi le jeu
trouve le team moi je ferais pas ça
parce que je trouve que micheal fait
tellement bien et puis sur ce terrain là
est saturé le modèle 8 vraiment à lui
mais pour aller dans le plus dit mais
c'est drôle j'en ai josette moins que la
dernière fois que je tarde à son patient
puis je parler quand il était venu à mon
podcast moyer pas à l'aise car c'est
plus sérieux il un peu le sachet zico
yem quand sa bonne chance dit et je le
connais danville sela la plus drôle qui
existe partout tout le temps c'est une
machine de l ex parfait pour l'huile
c'est parfait pour l'ust podcast mais
moi je trouve ça siffle ce succès le
succès de ce produit n'a aucun sens mais
seat s'y être défriché le terrain le
podcasting nous apprécions pur - peut
bénéficier de temps pour revenir à ta
question est foutue punch que quand tu
vois le seul c'est fait pour cela s'est
fait pour la performance un peu la
performance humoristique ne prenant que
tu fais aussi avec la foule jadwa une
forme d'un propres dépens moi je suis
comme un produit longue forme de deux
heures au est vraiment vraiment puis
mais c'est 50 connais michael qui tu te
fais avec sa vie toujours un peu en
performance en train de faire des jokes
horton qui appuie dessus rit beaucoup tu
sais que peu importe le sujet que ce
soit aussi dit qu'il veut trouver un gag
là tu sais que ce soit mathieu ppri qui
parle la mort de son père pour faire des
gags là dessus que nous importe quoi il
faut pencher là dessus c'est pile mon
agent c'est d'ailleurs notre dernier
vote y associe il me disait que je
faisais même quand il ya des problèmes
seuls aspects des jobs dans sa tête le
témoin au lieu de juste sérieusement
analysé ce qu'on fera plein miss fait
des jokes
c'est vraiment une machine à gaz les
pitres hyper chaud mort le genre mais
servier fait dans magique pour rayer
comment et quand ça se passe ton
spectacle ça se passe bien ouais ouais
je bénis fin de la phase de poules
ouais h 15 août on est allés ensemble
merci merci
c'était la première médiatique je pense
moi c'est la première médiatique et
auteur outremont ouais ya dessus et de
changer un peu de puits ou au monde pas
de temps je te dirai mange pas si je
suis moi toute la phase de rodage
d'humoristes ce jeu je peux t'en la
blanche de drm j'arrive très près c'est
les gens paient pour leurs billets fait
que j'essaie de livrer quelque chose qui
comme qui est un produit fini puisque
j'y ai pensé puis je pense que je peux
dire pas des feuilles le bien en train
de faire à peu près n'importe quoi lâche
et que si ça fait longtemps qu'ils aient
poma coulé dans le béton je te saoule je
te dirai chemin que je m'amuse encore au
travail changer petit truc mais c'est
pas mal
la spam à la même afin que je fais que
mettez doc ça fait quand même longtemps
je m'entoure je mérite était celle d'un
boxeur très longtemps fait ce show là
j'ai en fait c'est moi j'ai parti mon
festival le docteur mobile au à coiffer
ya quelques années le cndd cinquième
édition puis je m'étais donné comme défi
là chaque année de faire de nouvelles a
fêté un peu le best-of de trois années
celui qu'il avait trois heures que j'ai
chouine qui est dans une heure et demie
une activité ensemble qui avait une
ligne directrice le même effet que
c'était beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
travail
choules mais de fait encore des quinze
minutes de la gauche à droite
au total le juge des enfants de rodez du
matériel l'autre sujet qui est magique
et même pendant ce spectacle qui jure
sur 12 mois même si c'est quand même
j'aime nasty quand même là l'humour on
joue tout le temps que tu sois au top
si tu t'en fous j'en ai vu le 18 mai
récemment mené arrêté pendant x nombre
d'années le trouve un an ou deux puis
amerrir fiennes l'api trouve son reflet
ça va vite le psy très compétitif c'est
ça c'est un art qui évolue quand même
rapidement sans qu'on s'en rende compte
l'autre c'est moi je les vois les jeunes
l'appui je touche jouant au bordel au
terminal pizzas puis
ouais sont les jeunes sont efficaces le
cfs games puis puceul n'y a pas de
secret il faut que tu faute il y avait
faute en france a écrit fo sur du coup
tu rajoutes dgac
c'est vraiment toute une job de
l'artisanat quelque peu en train de
peaufiner le ta petite affaire trouve
émettons des réussir à prendre comme tu
dis si tu te prêter trois heures
maintenant 10e swing qui programme un
spectacle
mon impression c'est que le spectacle
avait pratiquement été écrit je sais pas
comment bien m'exprimer comme un bloc
c'est parce que c'était tous les sujets
sans trust centre et entre vous entre le
chevaucher tous les centres là c'est
vraiment bien que moi puis on dirait que
c'était vraiment mon truc c'était écrit
exactement bourse c'est pour donner pour
compte suivre dans deux de critique
sociale et à travers moi je te dirai que
si la france est aussi que c'est
pourtant pas si difficile que ce faire
vite et ensemble des jo que sur trois
sujets voir si j'ai mes préférences
j'aime et j'ai mis ce sujet de
prédilection j'ai misé angle de
prédilection aussi fait que si difficile
d'un briquet ce ensemble parce que ça
part tout le temps un endroit très
personnelle puis puis de mes intérêts
personnels fixes
ça a été assez facile de faire face
ensemble si je peux joindre d'humoristes
qui est qui et qui ont un personnage
puis une anecdote j'ai passé le monde
c'est toujours à peu près ma critique
sociale qui ayant bac hakim a fuck you
va craquer à la rébellion
seul but pis encore encore aujourd'hui
oui bâclé j'écouterai joggeuse de
machines pige capotait sur tom morello
puis en moi dernièrement j'ai comme une
période déjà remettons un genre de cinq
heures où est ce que je peux laisser
laissé de côté
mon tom morello atteint jusqu'à temps
que quoi ce qu'on aime c'est des
menteurs d'audioslave le genre tombe un
peu là dedans plus je me dis c'est vrai
que je tripais sur tom morello pleut je
suis un peu qu'est ce qui sera encore
plus je vois qu'encore aujourd'hui
évidemment kong l'establishment sur lui
la société plus qu un crime c'est vrai
j'aime la presse se pendant à peu près
pendant cette période je suis allé voir
en spectacle sortie chez camille révolte
moi je viens de là aussi le timon j'ai
grandi que les bridges est quasiment une
légère capoter là dessus puis tout ce
qui le mouvement punk est pas possible
de cinq ans mais pas de contestataires
en masse la leaf
ouais ouais ouais moritz et j'ai
toujours tripes et là dessus cg j'aime
cette émotion là justement l'histoire
d'un truc mais comme j'ai toujours aimé
ça que j'ai tant mieux si je peux
souffler sur chez certaines personnes je
pense que c'est nécessaire quand même
qu'on est endormi endroit et dans nos
enfants on est assis sur notre petit
confort pic important d'en sortir et
enfin quand je dis grande indiqué
anti-flag même pièce des paons ça fait
du bien sauf agréable rappeler ça parce
qu'évidemment vieillit on en oublie ses
idéaux l'amendé de plus on est jeune
très jeune on est souvent plus d alice
pour un révolutionnaire - plomb sera
monique le temps mais moi oui on notera
zaki une option for noise à faire lui
même et ouais tu sais pas mais je
l'espère complexe non plus la rébellion
note si ça peut être un peu des petits
changements dans nos villes
oui c'est ça j'essaie de ça a été
difficile le guide j'essaie justement
que mon spectacle parce que j'essayais
de réserve une rébellion pour tout le
monde qui est très bien
rébellion accessible pour monsieur
madame tout le monde fait que ces seuils
a fallu que je recule certainement fois
que j'en avance certaine aux autres puis
j'arrive
c'est ce que j'arrive je voulais je
lèche cul mais la bonne manière
je voulais brasser mais pas juste pour
brosser avec cette étoffe de trouver la
bonne ligne
moi je pense que le danger c'est que ces
personnes arrivent en place puis
de ce fait ce qu'il veut ça peut comme
réputés du monde mais je pense que tu as
réussi à pour faire la morale mais
décrit une gamme honda même gagné au
ballon nous ensemble et que je suis en
bac nord puis je fais l'amour mais si
j'aï celle de 6 ce concept lui faire la
morale c'est parce que moi chaque fois
des gens je critique je critique des
trucs qui m'agace [ __ ] mais t'es pas
obligé d'être d'accord je pas en train
de dire qu'il faut que je pense comme
moi je suis en train de dire comme elle
se sert pas de sens ce qu'ils puissent
eux aussi sa touche bien je sais c'est
ton problème après ça mange pas en train
de dire que ce que tu que tu devrais
femme et moi c'est ce que je pense mais
oui mais oui c'est compliqué c'est des
fois même si tu veux pas faire la morale
tola de faire la morale
enfin le faut que tu gates on a failli
mais ouais c'est vraiment le piège avec
le style d'humour que je fais le numéro
est un bon exemple de susciter numéro
sur le big air intérieur qu'un supporter
fait à la la carte blanche jean ouais je
t'ai l'oxymore ils ont évacué puis je
tiens ce numéro la scic est inclus toi -
danseurs en dix ans on a tout un viking
intérieur qu'il faut foulée c'est serpos
la grippe at-on à me mettre dans ma
glande qui revient elle a fait c'est
comme ça vient d'un endroit sincère
maintenant je crois cependant le mit
tout petit ça commence et quand mayette
ideas autre plan un moment donné il ya
des histoires qui s'applique ainsi j'ai
pas fait ce métro quand même si j'ai
prêté collecte des filles le temps que
ça dans le fond plus on était même pas
rendu compte qu'il avait quand mon dieu
qui va contre tous un certain niveau des
ajustements faire quand même bizarre que
ça n'a pas été honnête de ma part de
faire comme c'est des trucs qu faites
comme moi il ya des réflexions à vous il
ya énormément réflexion avoir tout dans
toute cette question-là du de suite aux
mythes ou maintenant la poste mis tout
le c'est important de en tant qu en tant
qu'homme de ce d'accepter de remettre en
question certains nos agissements parce
que c'est pas vrai qu'on était tous des
jo gook à ce point là
vraiment pas maintenant les choses
évoluent rapidement c'est fou le timon
georges peut regarder mettons mon
premier spectacle peut pas faire ça
passerait plus lourd du sang aurait pu
rapporter michael tu vois que je pensais
même eh ouais je pense qu'on est
vraiment une je passais internet les
réseaux sociaux qui accélère cela mais
ça va vite la maintenance a évolué
rapidement les les pensées de la manière
de penser évolue rapidement puis c'est
tant mieux tant mieux mais ce faux pas
ça fait capoter ce qu'ils veulent pas
sûr qu'ils veulent pas que ça évolue
mais le serment est levée le rester j'ai
beaucoup de danses morris aussi beaucoup
de tirs l'on peut plus réaliser puis
dans le temps on disait ça s'est passé
puisque - mettant mr une bonne nouvelle
quand qu'il faut évoluer faux france au
plus faut que tu sois plus créatifs faut
que tu prennes des risques mais d'une
autre manière
g - moi je voulais pas embarquer là
dedans je voulais pas je veux pas être
celui qui refuse le changement je
voulais être celui qui embarque dedans
petit qui se regarde le nombril c'est
une bonne sujet que j'aimerais qu'on
approfondisse exactement sur parce que
en lien avec on a parlé du film joker
autrefois mais moi je n'ai pas vu encore
un réalisateur de joker qui avant
faisait des screwball comedy il faisait
qu'ils aient fait d'ignorer old school
glover un pic expliqué pourquoi il
voulait plus faire d'humour puis son
raisonnement s'était déjà parce qu'on
peut plus rien rien rires mais on peut
plus rire de rien maintenant avec la
yaris la web culture inquiets puis la
salle a fait une grosse tôle et le plug
comme le producteur dealer même si
joaquin phoenix qui parle pour le film
c'est putois way - puis puisque c'est un
réel questionnement kg puis moi je suis
pas du tout dans l'humour pas du tout
bon et je veux dire gpo pratiquement
aucun sens de l'humour
fossard des fois je peux être drôle mais
comme j'ai pas dit maintenant tu me
demander de faire un stand up c'est le
pays regorge dont il avait dû manger ce
nouveau droit c'est ça c'est ça fait
c'est quoi
comment on aborde mettons tout c'est
quoi ton point de vue
c'est une question ultra flou que je te
pose ensemble à se figer imagine que tu
as déjà fait une porte de réflexion à ce
niveau là dessus mais c'est difficile
pour moi de juger ça parce que je n'ai
jamais vraiment eu de problème avec cela
si l'espèce de moins que coacher pin
puis souvent des collègues qui ont eu
des problèmes avec se jeter comme un
check tai chi 12 l'autre ici comme des
fous irrigue mais plus mal à l'aise que
quelqu'un qui revendique l'espèce de
liberté d'expression avec de quoi qui
hulule trop problématique petit coin
gentil fenger à lesparre quatre pilotes
se trouve qu'on peut plus rien disent
comme demont 6 mai mais je dis aux
pétales droit à la meilleure c'est
jusqu'à des conséquences en fait j'aime
dans mon show à malines pas tout les
jours que tu es juste des conséquences
maintenant essayer y avait un humoriste
que j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle d'un
rite romain qui l'a le logo du docteur
mobile a coiffé c'est lui c'est sa façon
humoristique et un documentaire sur lui
qui est vraiment très très bon il décède
isiolo maintenant mais dans un de ces
shows il faisait une blague là dessus il
disait que parler du mot est justement
là qui se plaignait de ce topic sommes
vraiment le tir comme vous êtes fauché
que des jeunes est maintenant assez de
personnalité assez de confiance pour
vous remettre en question le vous aimez
mieux dans le temps que c'est tout le
monde fait semblant que tout était
correct maintenant il ya maintenant
aider les gens parlent
puis s'ils sont année puis s'y trouve
que des sexistes et racistes ils vont te
dis oui il faut ça peut aller trop loin
note oui des fois ça veut pas dire
qu'ils ont raison mais
mais ça m'a jamais eu de problème avec
ce juste pas trop vraiment jamais eu de
problème avec cette fête des traites des
blagues cash acquittement mais c'est pas
le web coach qu'ils ont été chassés des
prêts d'être raucoules chaussée les
personnes concernées qui et d'équité
sauf que tu es tu sais que ta position
là-dessus ce que c'est juste une blague
puis ben t'es vraiment tu le reconnais
le fait que qui souhaiteraient de jack
kate aurait pas dû faire ça dépend ça
dépend oui c'est des blacks médecins que
j'aurais pas dû faire je vous aurais à
l'époque je les fais depuis jeté comme
sincère là dedans puis on peut pour
revenir sur le passé non plus loin mais
quand j'ai pas de regret mais clair les
enfants que je vais pas aujourd'hui
maintenant je pense qu'on prend la
nuance le schisme
si je dis les choses évoluent à cause
que tout évolue et que la société évolue
et la société évolue et puis mots si
j'évolue au travers de ce une chance
mais non c'est ça la fait c'est quand on
tire on parle de beaucoup encore très
peu de ça mais moi j'ai eu plus de
problèmes avec ce qui concerne moi c'est
plus un réseau qui me cause des
problèmes que les listes des
progressistes sochaux ce soir chacun
chacun su chacun ses problèmes m moi
c'est vraiment fort plus ces gens là qui
tout s'est tu où là c'est spectrale
parce que telle ni petit ni social je
sais ce voyage à pense parce que c'était
quand même un fera parler outre mer les
raisons qui sont plus touchés mais en
même temps dit clairement à gauche
pete est clairement mais moi je suis
celui qui s'aliène tout le monde aucun
ami dans le cantal ok mais je considère
que tu m'aurais c'est vraiment ça en
fait c'est vraiment cela job c'est de
jamais j'ai jamais voulu bâtir une école
à un certain public
ces machins critique sociale fait que je
veux critiquer tous les aspects de la
société nous et moi si tu suis depuis le
début c'est sûr que maintenant j'ai dit
quelque chose qui te déplu c'est sûr
qu'à un moment donné tu t'es senti
touché ou attaquer ou fait mais je sais
c'est pas un beau move business one est
littéralement tout le monde ouais mais
tu sais moi j'aime seule cette espèce
d'aspe le lait le lait le trickster le
tylenol le clown qui baissent les
culottes à tout le monde parce qu'en
vrai j'aime ça moi c'est l'aspect qui me
plaît le plus d'être humoriste de
pouvoir critiquer à peu près tout mais
les gens sont sensibles à l'intérieur à
l'intérieur du milieu de l'humour est ce
que cette position-là et populaire la
position de se dire moi aussi moi je
vais attaquer autant les humoristes qui
revendique le droit de liberté
d'expression que les socios que ce soit
eux qui vont l'être dans l'autre sens
que tout laisse toute l'ailé globe dans
le fond d'avoir pas vraiment le côté ou
un danseur pourtant pas plus large
aurait sûrement voir surtout qu'ils
meurent c'est pas mal un espèce de petit
clic homogène soutient que tu as des
qualités aussi le c'est comme un jeu
ayant l'impression de se voir comme un
chef de tribu lecomte le reste le puits
et puis le quad poffo la bande on n'est
pas toujours considérés comme des
artistes loti on est positif on parlait
pas vraiment considéré par les autres
formes d'art achetées aurait fait qu on
a toujours senti un besoin de cette
année en nous aux autres pilotes comme
les autres mais moi je sais moi je pense
que des aspects aussi à critiquer dans
le milieu de l'humour un puits puis je
le dis souvent c'est pour moi l'humour
c'est efficace quand ça enlève du
pouvoir à ceux qui en ont trop petit
canal + dans le show business généré
avec moi c'est parce qu'ils ont de
pouvoir tu sais mais ça ça plaît pas aux
collègues de jean jardin amis humoristes
récemment pis ceux qui prennent le moins
les jokes et l'île maurice confirme se
voit pas toujours ce qui se passe en
coulisse même mois les plus gros
problèmes que j'ai eus vous en
connaissez là mais les plus gros
problèmes que j'ai eus sato jo était
avec des humoristes chris kelly
l'arrière pendant dix ans ils nous on
n'a pas vu c'est moi même le huawei d
appel a dit à mon gérant pizza il le
faut qu'ils arrêtent de dire ce pilier
de telles affaires dans une entrevue
plus beaucoup ouais d'y prendre des
jokes mais quand guillaume wagner pas
toujours des jo le même si c'est drôle
parce que j'ai l'impression que ça on
sent souvent que si profondément ce que
tu penses non ben saad et m'écoutent ça
dépend antijeu dire c'est sûr que mes
jobs parle d'un endroit de vérité le
shaq jo par le nombre de vérités mais
même si je sais une chose au moins parce
que certains me tonti mike coughlan toc
un peu raciste métier tu sais qui part à
ce sit-in entre ici justement ajuste une
joke
mais maintenant que tu critiques un
humoriste qui fait des grosses peu mais
on le sait que tu penses pauvres et
ouais mais c'est vraiment je pencherais
pour vrai mais ça veut pas dire que j'en
pense moins de la personne non plus le
team moi je crie c'est qu'un aspect de
la carrière de ce que le contrat paul
mai
mais ça ne pose que je respecte pas son
travail que je respecte pas la personne
petite soeur c'est ça mais ce côté là
c'est très sensible île maurice andrieux
faut que tu leur expliques jpy devrait
le savoir c'est comme un pape une joke
sur tel aspect que ça veut dire que
j'attends j'attaque ma personne mais ils
prennent tout est affaire très
personnelle mais jackson joe club c'est
comme si c'est à l'extérieur de toi même
tu dis moi même quand je fais des
blagues sur les gens généralement je
m'attaque à à la personnalité publique
que je m'attaque au symbole de ce que tu
représentes la personne privée je disais
je ne ferai pas de jacques latu je la
connais probablement pas non plus le
titre the prodigy sur tes enfants la
tige faire des jokes sortait sur ta
personne publique se sait quelque chose
moi j'ai appris à le faire elle était
depuis force d'occupation depuis qu'elle
a comme titre
de fait ce tout en parle beaucoup de
bain beaucoup dans part relativement
beaucoup d'occupations doute ceux des
docks là-dessus argent dans des roches
chaudes c'est je crois ce il faut
s'apprêter automatique parce que j'ai
pas sa peau était progressif mettons le
moment un personnage public
le bayer pas grossi progressivement fait
que j'ai pas ôté comme attac éminemment
au début pour développer quelque chose
moi mais d'être capable de séparer qui
tu es aux yeux des gens pita personnes
arrivées comme tu viennes isère
ça c'est vraiment offre à mes côtés
avancée des années le showbiz lavanchy
vraiment que certaines personnes sont
capables de le faire
c'est long c'est compliqué c'est
possible c'est vrai que c'est paul von
le truc est celui mettant des
commentaires de sur facebook d'instiguer
au bac ne gèle la vie est pas bon à la
main tout y est y attaquent ma
personnalité publique ou bien ça touche
personnellement part ça me touche
personnellement je te dirais que ça
touche quand c'est constant et en vagues
le tir à un moment donné l'été comme
c'est paul von impôts c'est peu mais
c'est normal qu'ils n'ont plus le droit
à s'exprimer ces gens-là fait pis
faux faux je respecte ça aussi mais mais
mais oui ils attaquent ma personne
publique sans être connecté pour
personne oui oui et non faut quand même
que je fasse la distinction ces jeunes
ils connaissent pas personnellement puis
aime pas ce que tu fais c'est pour pas
plus grave que ça non plus le thé chez
je suis quelqu'un d'autre dans ville où
il ne fait que meiway c'est pas évident
s'est passé vraiment pas évident puis
c'est des années et des années le taser
de de subir des affaires a mené puis
d'être capable de se soucier de titi
c'est de la pratique patch est l'exact
piquant quand justement ça commence t
puis à moins que tu ta muay thaï en
overnight succès soit tu exploses
transferts publics dans le même qu'il ya
plein de monde qui t'aiment pas pu
pleinement qui t'aime pour aucune raison
là mais c'est ça commence par des petits
coupés problème qui peut te forger
quelque chose avec le temps chose que
moi j'ai clairement pas eu le temps de
faire ouais c'est comme d'arriver si kim
tak à poney 2 de vous autres écuries
comme fait des affaires la même caisse
que pipo et ça va être ça va être gelée
pas eu trop tough l'été il y en a qui
ont eu ce sera encore pire le métier de
com de voir disparaître parce que
parce qu'elle est soudainement le québec
au complet tu détestes moins quelques
jours cieux comme juste parce que ce qui
était montré s'est pas posé de questions
du moment où tu es pas à l'aise et c'est
comme moi je suis sa création d'objets
j'étais pour plein de raisons
ma blonde mais aussi un aspect l'aspect
fascinant niveau sociologique mais bon
trip là dessus c'est toujours une excuse
pour les mêmes raisons que moi mais
sociologique est intéressant mais des
fois la présence est irresponsable c'est
des fois il ya des gens là blanche
commis un peu instable t on de spots
toutefois sortir puis les gens qui ont
frappé la femme parfaite normalement je
trouve que c'est ces gens me parlait
beaucoup et avec avec la production puis
avec on en a parlé dans l'incertain
podcast je trouve que c'est vraiment pas
éthique non de faire de l'argent sur des
gens qui ont des problèmes mentaux
ouais c'est vraiment une problématique
tpo je vais la nommer parce que je suis
ça ne dérangerait pas me joanny qui
était mon année qui est et ouest étant
donné que le plus problématique de
d'autres d'occupation double depuis web
api web axes étaient pas sur les médias
sociaux fait qu'après sa finition c'est
ça mais et alors en rentrant là bas
était au milieu d'une thérapie qui
s'appelait louis borg quelqu'un fait une
thérapie ou est ce que tu te mets à nu
pis tu reconstruit sur toi mais c'est
quand même un temps c'est vraiment une
thérapie qui nécessite du temps qui
nécessite de la patience pi du thé de
reconstruire tranquillement étape par
étape sur des blocs fondateur celui qui
était au milieu de ce camp qui l'on
rentré dans le show phi phi service il
savait se présenter en dix ans ce sera
moi j'étais au milieu d'une thérapie
faites-leur qui il a choisi ce pour
faire ce puits au lieu de cas qui voit
dessins de break down
des signes de l amp détresse visiblement
ce qu'ils ont montré c'est pas tout le
team nous on avait des vrais signes de
comac et le faut qu'ils sortent des
maisons qu'ils fassent facetime avec sa
psy parce que dans un brigand à la place
de frères à qui on la retire de la de
dire on la met de l'avant
puis on y donne tout le screen times il
a l'air d'une folle romaine the omen je
trouve ça extrêmement problématique
comme comme décision de production
responsabilité c'est que je veux dire
c'est des adultes et ont signé pour ça
d'un coup qui embarque une passion
double montée de quoi ça à la fois mais
comment comment tu t'es tu as quelqu'un
de trisomiques par exemple si je compare
pas du tout joignant je crois pas mais à
quel point est ce que en temps où la
ligne ou est ce que tu te des charges
surtout si elle allait signer points
mais un moment est une décision à
prendre de dire là on va arrêter de
faire de l'argent sur le dos d'une
maladie mentale d'accord avec toi je
fais juste 6 je suis essayé de voir
d'autres c'est quoi leur raisonnement
d'ailleurs assez puis comment qui se
déculpabiliser ouais ya toujours moyen
de se déculpabiliser général mais moi je
suis d'accord avec toi y ait quelque
chose de problématique là bas puis de
ces commerces un coin un peu extrême
mais il y en ad'autres là dedans quelque
chose comme toi personne aimante aura
peut-être pas dû prendre cette décision
là ça prend quelqu'un extérieur qui
disent comme ce sera pas la production
le qui n'ont à présent qu'il ya un coup
de gens là dedans qui font bien confiant
sa production en fait que moi et ses
hôtes depuis j'ai hélas je pense qu'ils
ont assumée l'aspect humoristique
j'allais au deuxième un volet on va on y
arrive on bien se débrouiller l'asbam en
ligne est un peu le sens avec un clin
d'oeil puis sa fin un show 1 1 ça fait
un bon show mecha
line que je trouve cette idée fois cette
année je pense tous les coups de pêche
les coudes politique j'ai vraiment cette
année ont attiré qui est personne de
l'empathie pour personne et puis même
dit justement tu es c'est comme acquis
mettons keven viennent faire un gigot
brickdown et en pleurs pilotage idées et
savoir pas vraiment cadène qui laisse à
penser comme un peu super presque exact
c'est quoi
huawei mai et couettes je te dirai que
je les écoute avec probablement cette
attitude là aussi le genre on me demande
dans une fosse au lion va les gars vous
avez choisi d'être en fosse aux lionnes
+1 38 vous huawei ma foi de bellion qui
se promènent j'étais sûre d'avoir mal
fait mais ouais c'est écoute je sais pas
quoi en penser en fait je trouve que
suscitaient des personnages - mais ça te
finir sa vie n'est pas celle là
sauf qu'ici devrait être le problème le
prends avec ça c'est que même ça devient
un personnage c'est une faute sur deux
le le monde font pas la distinction
c'est juste la fessée c'est cette étude
des bilans white qui se fait insulter
pour son rôle dans la boutique non
unités neuves comme une cabine deux
présidents viennent de prison mais
chante tu as fais insulter par des
madame dans rue parce que à cause de son
personnage liman la voyait puis
l'insulté en pensant qu qui parlait à la
gardienne de prison impunité 9 qu'en
fait imaginer dans une série de fiction
comme unité 9 le transporter dans une
série de téléréalité où est-ce que c'est
toi dans certaines dents certains
paramètres le monde font juste pas la
distinction pas du doubs lundi s'être
regretté dans fait ça où tu étais pas
les ex et côtiers pas une journée où est
ce que je me pose pas la question qui se
pose encore la question comment fait-on
de tonton tu es pas en paix avec ça non
non là encore je me dis je me dis plus
ça va plus je m' en est loin
un jeu rythmé c'est quand tu regardes
ton genre n'aurait pas eu un podcast
querrey fonctionner autant si j'avais
pas eu autant d'abonnés sur instagram
qui me permettait d'inviter des gens aux
profils élevé il viendrait city ils y
apprennent à faire dans ma vie qui se
serait pas passé mais mon anonymes
hommes étaient chères comme ça qu'ils
mettaient plus cher que ce que je
croyais c'est au début le média non
c'est pas grave si je vous ai je pensais
pas que ça allait être comme ça si je
pensais pas que j'allais passer de
pouvoir sortir de chez nous puis que
personne ne voie à ce genre de chez nous
que pour une fois que je prends le métro
saint pierre des adolescentes qui rit en
pointant le ton puis ça c'est 60 des
anges mais ça va passer
c'est avec le temps je pense c'est
certain parce que c'est justement ce
n'est pas qu'ils se renouvellent
l'occupation de bon c'est toujours des
nouveaux puis les gens se rappellent
plus dans l'année en cours que les
autres années d'avancé on se rappelle
paul de l'année quatre anneaux mais ça
va se calmer
parlez plus du passé juste pour péages
décidée mais je pense que plus je m'en
éloigne plus ça va être chouette ça mais
encore aujourd'hui mais je pense que je
pense que comme ça vous devenir positif
ça va être comme injectons papiasse
telle affaire ça a changé ma vie je
savais déjà pas vraiment plu n'est ce
pas fait ouais bonne question impossible
à répondre parce que tu es le mettons
belge sceptique passion double justement
il fait le podcast et it avec jesse il
ya des recettes en épicerie qui est qui
s'en viennent éventuellement peut-être
c'est tout ça est cool m'est avis aurait
continué avant ses avis ses occupations
adopte aucune dit ça serait quoi
serais-tu plus moins heureux cette
différence est notamment très rarement
aussi heureux dans une autre vie pitié
aucun moyen de savoir qu'est ce qui est
quelque peu mais ce mois ci me fait
capoter aussi de je pense à tes nenê
tout est la première année j'ai 3 3 ok
mais si c'est plus un sou et chaussées
où c'est comme ultra positif maintenant
enfin occupation dos parce que c'est un
français
je fais ce que tu veux avec l'otan
serait positivement aussi fait que c'est
la première fois que c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'ultra pour une carrière
qui est quand même toi tu es quand même
temps tu parles de ton spectacle de du
stéréotype occupation de 1 tu parles
d'occupation double de 2 comme le groupe
jack qui vient encore plus quand même
bien que c'est sa version robe d'été
mais trop loin c'est seulement ce que
met la place d'être des gros gosse
débiteur est petit et un grand moule
c'est surtout stanis quand même des
barmen fidélité des dégâts et pays si ce
n'est pas tout des artistes des
intellectuels en attendant ce nom sauf
que c'est quand même plus peut-être un
peu plus raffiné mettant way
kenji me danseurs de 80 à l'époque mais
encore un peu là dessus aussi médecin
c'est sûr que moi quand je fais des
blagues je prends faute exagère les
truands ces conflits fils c'est la loupe
le tc je peux y aller en nuance le noir
je voulais qu'on parle aussi de temps
nouveaux
en fait à nouveau dans ta ville effecté
pas maintenant comment ça change une vie
mais comme on disait goethe à l'ong est
maintenant complètement une vie mais
quand je dirais que ça change une vie
complètement demeurent positives mais
quand même je dirais que c'est moi j'ai
toujours été très faut que sur ma
carrière
1 mais à faire complètement 100% focus
là dessus puis non seulement à ceux de
manière un peu malsain je me réalise est
au travers sa [ __ ] je sais que c'est
même pas vu de manière malsaine parce qu
on entend tellement seul comme c'était
se réaliser à travers une carrière mais
y'a de quoi de oui au delà demain quand
même quand tu réalises personnellement à
traves à ton travail
ça c'est parti du jour au lendemain la
demo genre je sais pas ce qui me remplit
maintenant l'été avant j'avais besoin de
cela dit tu paies le chopper les
applaudissements pilote je te dirais que
maintenance comme
savent pas vraiment diminué chaque fois
le fait comme acquis non faut je trouve
moi un autre moteur que ce parce que
puissent être ses salaires bizarre de
dire ça mais je te confirme que à peu
près tous les humoristes ont seuls si on
veut on veut on veut de l'amour est
admiré on veut des applaudissements ya
de quoi de malsain là dedans quand même
mois puis moi je dirais que je le lis pu
semi problème non parce que ça prendra
et v'là t'y pour aller devant 500
personnes là qui veulent c'est passé une
bonne soirée pire ils s'appuient que tu
as brève soit mal scène hip hop je te
confirme que leur avez 100% malsaine au
pis ça va très bien pareil parce que tu
sais ça s'apprend ça prend de motivation
mais moi c'est plus à ma motivation fait
qu'il faut que je faut que je trouve ça
ailleurs mettons le tifo que je j'essaie
de m'accomplir plus artistiquement puis
de communiquer et puis de communiquer
mes idées puis mes propos pisseurs faut
vraiment que je trouve mon phone là
dedans
et non ça j'ai perdu je pense ce côté un
peu plus superficiel ce qui est positif
mais je dirais que c'est quand même
gênant c'est john george 13h50 plus
dragué par le toujours plus gros plus de
billets plus de tout
il ya beaucoup de temps nomura qui a
vendu le plus de billets qui est le plus
populaire c'est qu'il pût être qu'on
voit le plus puissant puis j'ai jamais
été le pire la balle est choqué je
n'aurais tu pas celui qui peut être plus
motivés par ça mais quand même je vais
je dois l'avouer je lis a quand même sa
moitié
les gpus fait le chicago qui comme moi
comme un con comme en corée en ligne ce
bateau là parce que je suis dedans c'est
que lorsque tonga y avait été un mois
encore en mode 3 mois contre les mois
mais c'est vraiment intéressant ce que
tu es est-ce qu'il ya plein il est
complet à faire qui me saute et
maintenant la réponse est ce que
maintenant est ce que tu vois plus dans
ton métier comme delors versus 1 un
métier je sais pas si si si - je
m'exprime mal est ce que tu vois plus
et des performances moins en désir désir
du résultat plus ans qu'est ce que tu
désires faire passer est ce que si ta
motivation du mexique vraiment mal sa
motivation ses pommes le résultat fait
que les applaudissements l'appréciation
est ce que tu t'es tu vois plus que tu
fais comme une méthode de faire passer à
des orgies des messages mais de façon
artistique
ben moi je voudrais que tu vas passer
une idéologie un message non parce que
c'est pas ça jamais été mon but c'est
peut-être un manque de respect ce demi
ce communiqué shell que je trouve le
avec les médias des fois le com puis
comparées de mon réalisateur proches moi
j'ai pas de message à faire passer ce
que je te dis ce que je pense mais tu es
vraiment pas obligé de penser comme moi
tu sais je sais mon point de vue sur la
société
en fait c'est assez léger derrière ce
même si l'amiante s'effectue ça
t'intéresse c'est tout un certain
inspire je trouve ça l'fun mais vient
écouter ça mais je suis en train
d'essayer de faire comme leur ai pensé
comme moi c'est vraiment important de
sécher j'essaie de j'essaie juste de
communiquer comment je vois le monde
puis comment je trouve que le monde
devrait heitz mais c'est pour moi c'est
pas un message médecis quand même dix
mille nuances que je me sens que je vous
fais mais ouais moi ma motivation mais
ç'a toujours quand même été motivations
artistiques l'atide de face que je veux
faire de la manière la plus sincère
possible mais je saisirai qu'il ya le
côté business le côté le côté résultat
ultra important dans niveau à faire de
l'humour est une équipe aussi pu tenir
ces sites monde qui dépendent les
exactement beaucoup de gens autour de
toi qui travaille avec toi puis qui
veulent vivre dit ça j'ai toujours eu de
la misère à lier les deux
je te dirais que c'est de plus en plus
comme si je vraiment juste envie de
phase moins le goût de fabrice mais ça
vient des conséquences mais voilà ce que
je réalise avec les années de plus en
plus de conséquences probablement que ça
éclaircit un petit peu la question je
voulais poser au sens où
si la gratification est plus qu il
importe le plus
ou ces puces qui te fait te réalisé toi
même tu peux plus faire ce que tu veux à
100% sans garder en tête sur m raison
c'est une certaine liberté
un poids qui est là dedans qui est un
acquis et nice to call phones pitié qui
est ressenti aussi par le public qui
sont comme à ont pu faire confiance
quand même parce qu'il ya là-bas en
moins d'intérêt
c'était le feeling que j'avais surtout
afin afin de la médiatique qu'on était
qu'on était allé voir aborder un petit
peu ça te dit maintenant que j'ai eu un
enfant c'est devenu la chose la plus
importante fait d'être ici
honnêtement que c'est le fun que vous
soyez là mais c'est plus qu'un brave
puis ça j'ai l'impression que ça se
ressent ça se ressent que tu le fais pas
nécessairement pour oui tu fais pour des
rires parce que c'est ce qui fait ça se
ressentait j'ai l'impression que tu le
faisais pas pour les conçu à l'oeuvre
qu'on applaudisse tu ouais ouais mais je
voudrais rejoint jack là dessus dans le
show comme job mais c'est une vraie ou
jeudi qu'il était l'île maurice on a un
manque d'amour à combler même maintenant
il est comblé jeunes enfants il m'en
donne tous les jours le puits d'une
manière tellement intense puis sincère
que j'ai plus besoin de vous autres si
c'est pour un visa pour me remplir mais
mais j'ai besoin de vous j'ai besoin de
vous autres pour autre chose d'autre et
comme on pense que ça des changes dans
ce temps là ces jeux comme témoin de
11h45 huit-dix pour pour les rires les
applaudissements x je sais qu'on passe
plus un moment unique et sincère mais
mais j'ai toujours en réflexion là
dessus aussi loin c'est complexe
c'est ce qui ma [ __ ] en ce moment je
t'aiderai away puis c'est sous cette
wichita par les dessous et sur les quais
déclic journal
est-ce que ce qui le fait d'avoir un
enfant ça changer de route chose de ta
manière de percevoir ou de penser le
monde c'était plus signé que témoin c'en
est trop petit mais je suis moi je pense
que je suis moins cynique c'est le
cynisme sais c'est un peu se mettre à
l'extérieur du monde extérieur que la
société
je me mets pas au dessus je me met à
l'aise je me mettais à l'extérieur je
critique sa pige mans s'en détacher
c'est comme j'ai pas de jpod en jeu j'ai
pas game blessures le truc fait que je
m'en fous un peu le terrain fait dans ce
que vous voulez moi je veux rire d'être
ça le maintenant que j aime les jolies
et ouais il ya un an je sais mieux les
gars vous voyez quelqu'un l'écran vient
le temps qui va vivre dans ce monde le
fait que ce serait le fun ii 2 que de
bâtir soucier des valeurs on ne peut
plus positives et un petit peu plus
sans ces mêmes et ouais c'est ça ça
change quand même cette manière je me
sens plus impliqué dans la sphère ça
c'est sûr le truc ça ses qualités ses
défauts mais c'est un gros fan de joe
cole ça a toujours été quelques chose
que je pense que je reproche à georges
cravenne mais que je lui souhaiterai
extérieur z c'est comme pour moi c'est
tout ça c'est un freak show moi je suis
assez en première rangée je prends des
notes puis j'ai douze ont pillé une
qualité à ça mais en même temps ça
manque d'humanité des fois l'accès des
fois c'est un peu froid puis c'est un
peu ça sert à apprendre mais aussi que
même si on veut pas faire partie du
système par répartition en faire partie
le tipi temps tout parlait justement des
cantiques et mouvement mis tout pile de
feuilles des papes réflexion sur tes
propres agissements du passé ou tic et
puis on doit tout les avoirs métier
c'est pareil pour l'environnement c'est
pareil pour toutes les collectivités
on a fait tous pas on est tous un peu
détaché parce qu'on sent pas directement
concerné parce que ces 10 mars
mais on a fait de ce parti est le
premier cologix vraiment à ce sont aussi
tous ensemble la société qu'on écrit ça
c'est pas la faute de lui ou de langue
ou de lui mais c'est également le séisme
et puis oui on est tous responsables de
ça mais en fait je pense qu'il faut se
le rappeler mais il faut quand même
faut cesser du laus aussi souvent quand
on parle de son par l'environnement
petite fête
ce doit être tous et on chante ait fait
ou qui étaient faites comme a qui n'ont
vraiment pas pro culpabiliser les
individus le sauf que ce que c'est tu
peux pas non plus complètement détaché
pendant ces six mois je regarde c'est la
société se dit des malades
td fois justement que certaines
personnes partagent certains les
articles différents genres est quel
monde est fou et folk l'être humain a
tant qu individu peut être mais plus
l'être humain en tant que collectivité
c'est comme deux sources concordantes
vous voyez c'est quand même ce problème
là je trouvais que les progressistes ont
eu tendance quand même à s'exclure de se
soustraire comme moi je suis un ange
descendu du ciel
et voici les assauts enfin on a tous une
part de responsabilité quand même c'est
ce qui nous rend humain aussi ça nous
permet aussi de mieux comprendre l'autre
qui fait des affaires qui contrôle n'ont
pas de bon sens la petite piste vaut
mieux aller le chercher peut-être si tu
lui comprend un peu plus si toutes des
tâches pour moi je suis parfait puis
faites comme moi c'est des gros chances
que le message passe mal
vraiment vraiment moi je le vis beaucoup
avec le véganisme l'un d'eux comme
incident le moindrement que tu fais une
affaire qui est pauvre impeccable le
faire reprocher puis ça fait juste pour
reprendre l'expression aliéné ça fait
juste allié non encore plus à la cause
de forêt y mène je fais vraiment mes
efforts le mais je sais pas même qu'il y
avait une fiche de qui vient d'une
cheminée dans mon dans mon gilet je sais
pas ça fait en sorte que les gens ils
font comme si tu vois je
certains pointent et j'ai même pas
comment être parfait adam il faut que je
voie partagée mais pas comme un chef au
coffre jusqu'à un an pour voir comment
ils seraient normalement la de la marque
ceux qui essayent plus en plus critiqué
ce que ses médecins qu'il maison
pour ce qui est beaucoup de monde qui
qui refusent de comme chez mettre des
étiquettes des ti y ait plein vegan qui
disent pas que son véhicule juste
pourquoi justement entrer dans cette
danse le le de jouer assez chi chi le
plus pourri alexandre l'annoncer
maintenant tous les mouvements en france
c'est comme pour ceux plus peur que
péter vegan n'était même pas zéro déchet
[Rires]
j'aimerais ça va rencontrer cette
personne là c'est la personne parfaite
relevé ian zéro déchet qui est dans une
grotte il y en a qui ça existe c'est
mettons y retrouvera une fois raymond
gueule par les culpabiliser ses origines
métissées que ça peut aller loin
et puis souvent même pas ce que c'est
mais ton l'exemple des deux il y avait
une recette pour faire du déo comme on
m'aide avec du bicarbonate de soude
mais ça marche pas comme ça ça marche
pas de deux heures après tout sans le
sou et ça ne fonctionne fait que là je
comprends que c'est c'est mieux pour
l'environnement puisque s'encourage pas
une grosse compagnie quand gillett à
faire des c mais crise c'est la marche
pour que le maire s'appuie encore l'être
le moindrement et au chaud c'est fini
et puis je pense que tu es culpabiliser
les gens personnellement il ya quelque
chose de problème là dedans parce que je
trouve que si on a les choix qu'on ne
sait où on est on
on y est on est pogné dans ce système là
de ma faute ce système de transport tgv
le super efficace au travail du québec
je le prendrais l'autriche et la
rendrait pas mon choix pour aller faire
mes choses si je serais bien content de
ce mémoire quand même j'ai pas le choix
de prendre un charlot gaz parce que si
je veux je vaux bien loin du champ
électrique sera de poche que le fait que
j'ai pas le choix le jeu faut que je
fasse ce choix là mais c'est pas de ma
faute si tu culpabilises là dessus je
joue pas comme ça des pressions sur
gouvernement d'annoncer de changer cette
même mairie d'orly c'est le pack à ce
que j'écoute évidemment qu'on parlait tu
es tu on est petit zinc hypra son char
pour polluer leurs champs pour se
déplacer qui est la conséquence équipe
onu mais s'ils avaient choisi l argent
qu il prendrait les feux course c'est
pour vous faire chier j'ai fait quelque
chose de mal pour les plaisait dans les
options aux gens de faire mieux sans
déstabiliser toute leur quotidien et
c'est pour ça aussi qui prennent mal
quand tu la tenue des pointes droite
comme un châtain truc c'est normal c'est
vrai que normand s'est fait seule la
personne parfaite je tamaki vegan 0
d'échecs qui vit dans finalement qui
prend pas au tour auto suffisante aux
sauteurs qui épaulent pis si ça fini que
6e sa vie c'est sa personne le et puis
moi reste le et portal
c'est important parce que c'est
tellement du travail qui mettait dans
une société on a besoin du mans reste
aussi pour nos besoins
mais si on avait rencontré à un moment
donné du monde un couple qui avait
décidé face à la tête complètement tout
fut suffisant pige en espèce de petite
fermette machin genre énergie solaire
pittsburgh c'est que c'est leur vie si
elle a trouvé ça trouve ça cool c'est
parce que tout le monde on trouve ça
nice le crumble que ça et sochaux
inspira c'était l'argent si ce réseau
sont comme les deux est en dépression
totale au
il arrivera ça si je dis on s'est
construit c'est comme ça qu'on s'est
construit l'humanité les gens à qui moi
je juge et l expertise et l expertise on
va travailler ensemble et on va
s'organiser justement pour gruter moins
quand il fait tout seul sac
[Rires]
ouais moi je suis un gros fan de
réglementer tout cela c'est tout les
enfants réclamant témoin s'appuient les
gens sont liés ils vont être obligés de
faire les bons choix le moment donné m
la responsabilité c'est ce qui
maintenant à baisser mouvement le défaut
comme même ton le pacte c'est comme tout
le temps le poids sur l'individu juste
quand même moi c'est pas ma job de que
tout soit impeccable je disais pourquoi
moi j'ai toutes mes choix sont toxiques
c'est non mais oui et gérer vos affaires
moi je suis un gros fan il ya beaucoup
de et beaucoup de mouvement ce moment
des jeunes qui poursuivent le
gouvernement à cause de l'environnement
etc comme vous ne l'avez pas donné vous
ne donnez pas de quoi qui fait c'est pas
fait attention pis va falloir payer pour
ce qu'il va falloir changer des affaires
moi je suis un gros fan de ce camp même
chose moi aussi moi je pense que c'est
vraiment parle là que sa part cela on en
parlait l'autre fois une cup en direct
ce qui s'apprend c'est un espèce de
dictateurs environnementale ça prendrait
ça s'apprend des indicateurs
environnementaux que votre joker parce
que maintenant c'est ce parti que
j'apprendrai genre voilà qui est un
extraterrestre qui a réussi qui soit
genre ultra plus fort que tout le monde
qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils mènent pour
sauver la planète g7 forum sur le fofo
ce faux papiers aucun crise de lobby qui
vont pas changer mon idée parce que la
bible n'a aucun pouvoir sur moi ouais
mais titre d'une semaine en ce moment
c'est sûr mais à l'inversé ccc des
gouvernements qui sont ici par permis ce
soit avec les compagnies ajax et seul
problème les autres sur leur politique
c'est une dictature de l'autre bord même
et ses lions de l'index les interdits
peter métiers des pays qui font se
penser en uruguay qui ont fait comme
outman santo puis des pays qu'ils font
c'est comme c'est pas se pose pas de
cocaïne négatif
ils vont vont s'organiser autrement
piaui c'est pour mieux vivre
c'est clair mais ça c'est vrai que c'est
un réel problème je m'y intéresse de
plus en plus surtout sur l'est justement
les lobbys leti le lobbying puis comment
commencer d'ici le faire changer des
choses parce que tellement d'argent qui
bac tout ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
laitiers mettons-les justement tu sais
tu qui dit ce qu'est le pétrole tilelli
men irradie qu'est le pétrole c'est
c'est l'industrie qui est le plus
d'argent
moi c'est l'industrie qui vont le moins
se laisser abattre
y a rien qu'on qu'on peut faire c'est
voltige en copeaux de dood en
veston-cravate font du lobbying pour les
compagnies pétrolières sont maintes fois
plus puissant que cinq cent mille
personnes
rude et s'il vous plaît on sort une voix
un peu tout dolia large i-trans manton
les tenues par les couilles l'annoncé
par google de façon à paul non au québec
et on y prend de mâcon moi j'ai
l'impression des politiciens juste en
bas dans ce deuxième le tac on prend
quand même le pays ce que pour pouvoir
vraiment peas et les intérêts de qui
représente pas ennuyer jusqu'alors pour
sourire puis faire les affaires de fun
au pire et je pense qu'ils se vouent un
petit peu il se détache un petit peu de
recul je pense pas qu'ils aient gens me
lance pas vraiment que les six valeurs
profondes
ils sont mises de l'avant je suppose que
ces gens-là et noir et aux states et 6,6
en ligne saas et les conséquences les
conséquences sont claires déjà qu'ils
prennent des fusils qui ont acheté
légalement qui tu dois être humain avec
le sait peut pas être plus noir sur
blanc sur papier que pinto des malades
et justifie ses hôtes il ya tellement de
pouvoir et d'argent qui est ça je vois
pas à court terme moyen terme comment
que ça peut changer les lois la botte
aussi longtemps que doit-on temps de
pouvoir c'est particulier c'est culturel
le gone
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment être en
jambes coincées dans constitution c'est
leur histoire puis c'est drôle car il
comme si
c'est comme pour ré pourvoir se rebeller
contre le gouvernement puisqu'il quel
humoriste feusisberg la messe camions
des drones c'est toi tu tombes secondes
ça va pas changer grand-chose même ewell
et le lobbying c'est vraiment un énorme
problème
ces six mois constat pas qu'on vit
vraiment dans une démocratie ne fait que
je n'en avais assez problématique mais
en fait la responsabilité des individus
a fait l'individu on est aussi un gros
lobby commenté je devais faire une
marche de cinq cent mille personnes
vivent pas ça a un certain poids par été
est-ce que j'en annoncé seul problème je
pense que ouais moi je pense qu'ils
comptent mais assez de pression c'est
justement tu es des débutantes aux ondes
il faut permettre à la cub
l'irresponsabilité les responsabilités
sur les individus mais je pense quand
même notre rôle de mettre la pression
sur ceux qui ont réellement de pouvoir
le mettre assez de pression tu parles
assez fort d'aller dans la rue pour que
ça change en othe et huawei métier moi
je jeu découragerait jamais personne ne
le fera puis c'est important de le faire
le ce qui coûte le jeu dur continue et
puis mais au final c'est moi je pense
que le printemps arabe a été vraiment
décourageant pour la plupart des gens
parce que c'était une revendication
quand même assez clair pis finalement
les gens qui sont tapés dessus puisqu'on
disait comme nom ou un mec n'empêche que
rien n'empêche conquis que gagner
là-dedans
juste comme les jeunes je pense la grèce
et flottille ont mieux camoufler la lah
hauspie
c'est ça a été écoute salut pour saluer
n'est pas quand même major le ticket si
on n'avait rien fait c'est sûr c'est sûr
mais encore aujourd'hui mettant et le
gouvernement qui veut qu'ils voient se
réattaquer cette question le lycée d'un
quick s'embarque je pense que je pense
qu'ils indiquent quand même on a ce
pouvoir le métier se mettant toute cette
question là même ça a été des des mois
et des mois de grève puis de marée
humaine des matricules 7,28 et ça a été
un mouvement et a viré et 3 un
changement de quelques centaines de
pièces ouais le budget était grosse
cicatrice sur un peu plus pour des
niaiseries le tricot des affaires que le
gouvernement a dû changer comme se faire
comme aoki dont on vous entend vous
écoute vraiment une vraie démocratie de
son art est vrai des populations
auraient y aurait une consultation
publique pour l'environnement climatique
faudrait qu'il y ait cette marche le
tout les vendredis que ça c'est ça c'est
sûr vingt cinq cent mille personnes en
tout les vendredis qui font la stas et
puis l'on travaille peuple est assez
puis qu'il y avait tout le temps cinq
cent mille personnes a augmenté mais
c'est comme ça que ça avait perçu une
fois la semaine d'après et 75000
personnes 500 personnes qui marchaient
mali vendredi je vois de plus en plus
semaine en plus de plus en plus les
conséquences vont être j'espère
grandement tout pour ça mais j'ai encore
et je partage un petit peu ton cynisme à
l'idée de ce à l'idée de le guen le
gueux qui fait tout les cachots où les
quelques gars ou parce que c'est
sûrement des hommes blancs d'oeufs qui
font toutes les caches en eau de tulle
un autre cas est cinq cent mille
personnes qui marchent sur montréal 1
vendredi en ce moment sont à monaco en
train de
bois wever de phoques qui vaut un
million labois la bouteille l'été puis
il s'en crise il sans sac man qui avait
cinq cent mille personnes qui marchent
sur montréal - mathis est entré chez moi
ce n'est que vous rendrez que je me dis
qu'il est d'avoir une coupe qui doivent
trembler dans leurs bureaux
pourquoi n est pas ce qu est il le
virage mettant le virage vers
l'électrique les des voitures il entend
j'en conviens lalande
mais divisés à petit c'est quand même
possible de penser que des méthodes en
50 ans tout rond de vol électriques
je pense que c'est quand même possible
de l'alberta qui en ce moment même
qu'ils sont juste complètement à
l'opposé qui tire de l'autre bord
complètement parce que d'autres c'est
leur économie piqué je pense pas que
dans cinquante ans maintenant on est
électrique tout le monde quand tu vois
mettons des compagnies alimentaires
justement qui au lieu de kiki qui les
gagnent hyzler leur offre d'affaires
comme se tait quand même l'impression
que même si ça va passer rapidement puis
même si on fonce tout droit dans un mur
parce que je te mangerais que le
changement soit drastique imi limina on
s'en va quand même dans la bonne
direction le titre le 2e ligne record du
monde de l'histoire du plus de vols en
une journée
un vol de vols d'avions je veux dire à
quel point on s'améliore en ce moment la
consommation de viande en amérique du
nord a augmenté année à quel point ça
augmente si on a battu le record du
monde de tous les temps de la journée où
est ce que le plus de vols aériens qui
ont pris les qui ont pris les airs
quel point on s'améliore seuls les vols
l'avion c'est comme le paradoxe parce
que c'est on le sait que s'il tropez
l'ua mais on en parle pas tant pas
vraiment plus des voitures et les avions
qui les millennials superbe
deux à quatre fois par an imeca qui va à
la plage par exemple à bali ramasse des
bouteilles de plastique fier de lui mais
moi je suis content mon cynisme et le
next level je te dirais que ça va se
régler libre pour se régler mais ça va
s'améliorer à partir du marché parce que
si on voit dans ce c'était quelqu'un qui
en a une coupe et un couple de
compagnies qui vont comprendre c'est
plus le vigan c'est payant et un mk
paulo et qui sont prêtes à payer cher
pour ça fait qu'on va maintenant
commencer peut-être pour ça que c'était
pour ça qu individuellement c'est là que
sachant que trois gardiens du pouvoir
d'achat le point ces écoutes grosse
machine humaine et complexe qui
s'imbriquent c'est comme une grosse roue
qui roulent le plus fort king longtemps
l'iran titeuf ssp quoi je sens juste
parler d'être à l'extérieur de ce livre
dans son communiqué sondages et on est
rendu lé canton les marcheurs ils
roulent vers le mur et garde ses parents
ont décidé de repousser le mur un petit
peu mais j'ai comme j'ai pas de solution
j'ai pas de réponse à ça mais c'est d'où
mon cynisme des filles est maintenant
assez ça maintenant tommy des jetons en
partie vrai ça vient ça devient
difficile de bien courte mois de c'est
sûr jeudi j'ai des amis qui sont que
moins lotis mais donne enfin au monde
dans ce monde devant un pays responsable
à pittsburgh comme moi je suis venu dans
un monde qui était patent plus là dessus
s'est tenu dans le même monde juniors
jeunes au monde un seul système
capitaliste sauvage vite sopi j'ai mon
fan la banque armé multi j'apprécie à la
vie pu m'en contente d'être là je compte
en existe et les quand même de co2
niveau existentielle de préférer pop up
c'est pas mettre au monde je trouve ça
laid quoi des bruits de la banque
mondiale mais à quelle époque tu
retournes réalité ou loin quand est-ce
que ça l'est tant mieux je comprends
qu'il y avait pour m le climat du monde
au moyen âge
il savait rire des produits manger des
patates cuites à la moitié la population
sur les rythmes des enfants quand même
fait signer des baux moyennant quoi les
enfants changeront plus quoi ça devrait
marcher dans les rues ça changera pas
les armes
je serais curieux des fois des comme
parler qui es-tu c'est impossible de
parler à quelqu'un d'autre et que juste
pour avoir cette conversation
c'est quoi les enjeux qui préoccupent
aujourd'hui le toit paysans qui n'a sous
la gouverne d'un roi
c'est drôle j'ai parlé avec francis
dupuis déri on parlait de démocratie
pizza pizza à l'époque au moins large
la démocratie tu es mieux ces petits
bizarre penser à ma commune ait plus de
pouvoir
c'est juste de bouyer un roi l'acquis
poignet tout petit sommet mais il
s'occupait pas vraiment t'aider petit
village et paysans puis ça fait que
d'autres s'organiser entre autres y
avait des échanges entre autres équipes
il y avait un pouvoir décisionnel sur le
web calimez fait qu'elles vivent plus
dans une démocratie que nous août les
gens époque médiévale dont je suis dans
la bouche on s'est un peu traumatisé
c'est aussi qu'y at il de plus les
outils le belge
je les connais pas le paysan mais
j'assume qui avait - les outils
intellectuels ou cissé be l'information
pour pouvoir réfléchir à sa situation au
sipi c44 pollet formation aux autres
sont dans les rues pour pour revendiquer
l'environnement parce qu'on est informé
de six mois c'était pas informés
cependant ils n'ont plus assez clair tu
peux te rends compte que tu habites un
peu de la marne par jonathan chat mais
messi c'est un autre petit ça me fait
passer par là ton show justement du sud
ses coutures il peut des milléniaux et
celle fille quand même cela dit quel
point qui arrivait de là dedans puis sur
cet aspect là j'en conviens mais on est
quand même je pense une génération
they do autant qu'on est narcissique
mettons du point de vue réseaux sociaux
on est quand même
crissement soucieux de la collectivité
pour ce qui est de l'environnement j'ai
plein de questions sociales qui comme un
genre de paradoxe mannequin narcissique
non non il ya plein de kouté pou si
c'est lui je le dis en plus dans ce
numéro l'homme et s'échange mais je n'ai
pas trop de deux pour là dessus qu'on
parlait que nuancée pause par
efficacement nouveau même eh oui un
aspect positif si les gens sont plus
informés de séduction lis des articles
sur de partout dans le monde
si je dirais moi je peux m'informer avec
deux gardiens d'autant que la presse
fait chier vraiment plus informés sur la
plupart des enjeux puis toutes les
opinions que j'ai en ce moment on voit
mal formé par à partir de 110 montceau
mais il ya quand même quand même ça
s'appelle aussi le qui moi me fascine
choses assez fascinant le narcissisme
ton s'est développée puis on est comme
dans un arc narcissisme jantes 2.7 tout
même trop au point zéro loup quand on y
être consciente qu'ils ont nés de ce
qu'on projette puis de ce conte de conte
et une mise en scène novices et des
mises en scène maintenant ça va toujours
été à quelques pas mais là on peut
contrôler plus les paramètres de notre
mise enceinte mais je trouve qu'il ya de
quoi de conduire la dame je le dis dans
mon chez moi j'ai vécu le avant internet
après tout ça évolue mais je trouve sa
source assez fascinante des fois je me
sens un peu dépassé aussi le sait
sûrement même moi je me savais pas c'est
souvent un loto géant
j'ai eu une illumination cette semaine j
me franchimont fine instagram
puis les 6 premières photos
c'était une fille en selphy ouais tout
le monde que je connais personnellement
maintenant même si on s'est peut-être vu
quelques poils mais c'était la même
photo la même photo prise par six
personnes différentes posté à 5 heures
parce que c'est le gars le plus
d'affluence sur un style
l'échappée si ce que j'ai fait j'allais
voir ma blonde je regarde ce petit rôle
et les six photos j'ai fait je suis plus
capable je fermais en application puis
j'ai décidé activement de juste ouvrir
instagram le moins souvent possible à
partir de maintenant parce que mène il
n'y avait rien de pertinent avait rien
de pertinent reste isolé je m'imaginais
c'est que moi je veux dire j'en suis pas
tant que des belles filles prennent des
selphy j'ai ensuite parce que je les
connais
mais là je me disais tête à tête une
jeune femme ou une jeune fille
aujourd'hui le quai dans celui des
centaines tandis que seul fait qu tu
ouvres ton fils puis après en avoir six
en quarante huit d'affilée
qu'est ce que tu fais tu as peut être
parce que les quatre chambres est
inspirant même pas ce qu'est une belle
leçon de vie dans le cap sizun par en
dessous de tout
c'est ça mais c'est comme s'il ya de
quoi là dedans des quais qui est
fascinant justement cette masse critique
qu est ce que c se sait rien de plus que
ce que c'est et s'essayer le genre que
je sais moi cubells mouche baudelot
china est donc ma vie est vraiment cool
soyez jaloux souple mais d'avoir la
meilleure formulation c'est quoi ce rien
de plus que ce que c'est des fois on
peut essayer de jeter j'en entends quand
même essayé de pousser plus loin et puis
de faire comme moi maintenant même temps
mon communicante nous autres pizzas puis
comme je comprends ça mais je trouvais
un quad dangereux l'attend à un moment
donné deux objectifs de passer
maintenant une heure ou deux c'est de
trouver ton bon profil qu'ils trouvaient
je dis ceci pour c'est vraiment oui
c'était une heure je devrai peut pas ch
pour avoir une introspection profonde
lire un livre en même temps la business
dur
jalloul d'avoir une introspection
profonde c'est quoi je pense c'est
important de le rappeler ce parce que
c'est ultra normalise et puis on se pose
plus la question puis on fait plein de
gens le font pisser justice on vit dans
ce monde le pim et d'y être bizarre j'ai
un recul de france au regard extérieur
manège des paniers deux minutes de
regarder mon instagram cpie mouche 0
influence à ses péchés crise je suis sur
toutes les photos que je suis le sujet
et oui c'est sûr les les photos sont
montrés peu plus de jeu posté mais ton
post est maintenant mes pédales mon
appli type il est un genre trop light
il expose une bonne photo de toi qui
fais quelque chose ou kit avec ton ami
podcast avec la chaîne badouri notamment
une plaie c'est comme ça pognait en foot
et taclait finalement tu fini par
concentrer tes trucs sur ce qui marche
bien je me dis qu'il me semble que je
t'aime à regarder mon fils juste le
stupide et narcisse excellent et ses
affidés qui remercie le monde dans
lequel on invite ses membres de ma
blonde aussi et a fait de la musique
ping an qui postent j'ai pas dis des
trucs plus arty ou cdd de la musique les
gens sont plus ou moins des chevaux qui
met une photo de deux comme le lien
temps tout ça s'apprend mais le reste
tout ce qui pas tout ce qui bouge en
focus et surtout ça j'essaie d'être
attentif à certains comptes de monde qui
ont vraiment des gros following mais qui
ne sait pas tout le temps à d'autres
sujets que j'essaie de comprendre
comment y remédier et mettons tout béton
alexandre champagne ce qui est
photographe rocchetti lui réussit à être
avoir un compte faute d'engagements
qu'il faudrait qu'ils suivent mais pour
autre chose que je sais sur lui sa
famille si allemands instagram cet effet
pour les photographes
c'est une application que les
photographes puis plainte qu'en me suis
plaint de photographes de paysages
surtout lucky qui publient des belles
photos mais des belles photos ça va
toujours
chez moi j'ai essayé comme de faire un
peu mon clean up
suite à cette aventure la d6 selphy
défend cleanapp de mon fils pour essayer
d'avoir jeté truc que je trouve ce soit
vraiment intéressant ou des trucs que je
trouve
esthétiquement vraiment beau au delà de
la beauté d'une personne que des filles
belges dans les vinyles fait si souvent
des photographes de paysages qui font
des photos vraiment malade cepici contre
l'as ont énormément suivi mais sitôt pas
si je le souhaitais pas un photographe
instagram c'est peut-être pas la
plateforme sur la scéne rôle de plate
forme quand même mais ces pistes
c'est pour moi maintenant facebook s'est
même défoncement enceinte dans nos
opinions aussi le sait même pas où se
déroulent des fois on s'en veut allier
on veut aller chercher du on a cherché
de l'engagement avec des opinions comme
qui sont son extrême son punch et peter
on est on est là dedans on est vraiment
une génération de mise en scène et on
est bon dans la communication puis ça
mais on trouve qu'on a un petit peu trop
intégré les codes du narcissisme pour
eux pour avoir des interactions qui sont
humainement scène c'est ça peut l'être
la mèche et entre jeu de ce que
j'observe puis ma réflexion n'est pas
aboutie là-dessus mais je nous trouve je
nous trouve dans la mise en scène d'
extrême vraiment pu même même les
journalistes entre guillemets ou les
éditorialistes se met en scène un homme
en moins c'est maintenant s'est rendu le
concours de qui va être le plus son
personnage
jean martineau il considérait conscient
de son personnage sur qui il dit des
affaires que il ne répèterait pas après
qu'un qu'irène discussion et c'est dans
un podcast sur qui écrit des trucs juste
parce que c'est son personnage d'un
personnage dire est ce plus dérangeante
du monde sans se poser avant un opinion
[Musique]
nuancée sur certains sujets qui font
juste allé all-in dans le personnage je
mange bien on se ramasse avec
d'information qui est juste très
personnel très payant être un être
humain personne qui pense qui nuance et
qu'ils aient des doutes aussi le tennis
de france chez poteau de l'api c'est des
fois je m'avance sur certains trucs qui
sont sûres de la scène c'est c'est une
mise en scène je fais que ça c'est tout
et très corrigé là dessous de tout là
bas c'est normal parce qu'il faut que ce
soit ça vous fait ça prend pas de doute
animaux mais dans vies tous les jours
c'est une personne qui a des doutes pips
puis ça c'est pas payant s'essayer dans
ces jeux des fois je prends des
positions puis il ya des gens sont comme
fâché parce qu'ils ont l'impression
c'est pas ça mon personnage se dote d'un
mode versus com - mais jeudi on est
complexe et si on n'accepte pas ce tant
que ça parce que je pense qu'on consomme
en fait on est des consommateurs en
consomment
on consomme des êtres humains on
consomme des photos instagram ans on
consomme les gens mais on n'est pas en
train de vouloir dialoguer communiquer
avec des gens on veut on consomme pour
pour nous mêmes c'est pour se rassurer
sur nos vies genève reçoit souvent
exactement exactement parce que souvent
le monde vont suivre juste les gens qui
vont les réconforter sur leurs
nombreuses opinions c'est le
télécharment dès qu on entend souvent
les familles charme des coq et tout
autour de monde qui ont juste mon
opinion petit fait juste bande c'est ta
propre pignons verts toiletter le monde
qui lise richard martineau je demande
souvent du monde qui vont adhérer à son
opinion qui vont pas lire le poser kim
puis même chose pour moi l'amour son
mars noir le lipow parce que ça
m'intéresse pas et semble sont ses
points de vue aussi peu nuancé sont ils
m'intéressent pas d'écho tous une chance
le fait que fais tu consommes tu
consommes qui dirait confortent dans tes
propres affaires ouais je m'en prends le
mac pro ne manque ici philippe reines du
circuit comme se consomme exactement ce
parce que tout le monde sait ce qui
m'agace le plus on met le doigt dessus
at il donné des consommateurs on est
intégré le fonctionnement de la
consommation pizzas puis on se voit nous
mêmes comme des produits comme des
marques étaient on bâtit note markit
s'appuient moche et je vais à bijoux et
même mon brave associé avec un autre
brennan pétition devient ouais on est
des hauts et des très très bon
consommateur on ne réalise pas tout le
temps mon un bien intégrée tout se sait
ce qui c'est ce qui me déprime le plus
je pense de ce qui se passe en ce moment
on parlait de dickens de machines
pantois c'est une époque moutons comme
nirvana
ce team attentes étaient était un petit
peu bouleversé avait encore un espèce
d'impact c'est mais maintenant les gens
sont pourtant ces sols c'est le monde
dans lequel on vit
c'est sur les paramètres intégré ou
votre impression c'est beaucoup ce notre
mentalité en ce moment
paradoxalement c'est le mot authentique
jamais plus de 60 ans il rentre chez sa
femme c'est comme un corps nos jambes et
[Rires]
d authenticité hawks ça parle de ça
justement là comme ça quel point de
galvauder cet amour le pied à quel point
c'est devenu un vrai nom actuel pipi
c'est tellement éloigné de ce que tu
faisais même au niveau philosophie comme
être authentique à toi-même de sticky
vraiment walt est profondément
c'était en mouvement le titiller pas un
toit purac pas fait que ben ouais c'est
pauvre mollahs mais oui c'est ça puis
l'as far aussi c'est que même quand on a
l'impression de l'être c'est parce que
justement des personnes par les doutes
mais des ddd des personnes influenceurs
qui expriment leurs doutes dans un
sécurité sur les réseaux sociaux il y en
a tout le temps tu sais pas ce que c'est
humain puis si authentique mais
n'empêche qui est du moment que tu fais
comme ça vient de briser quelque chose
est brisé un genre de même si c'est vrai
tu leur icrete relayant en scène pour
que les autres le voient puis il ya
quelque chose qui s'est perdu lass moral
puis aux autres
de l'extérieur on peut être que des fois
on le on le fait trop métillon on
critique où on remet en doute
l'intention leurs intentions derrière où
le temps cité de sopi tu peux dire le
local fait juste pour les différents
comme care rachedi venu ici qui est fait
son coming out de trucs qu il soit
ouvertement qu'ils vont dire ouais mais
il fait ce parce que si son nouveau
branding qui vont taxer les deux il ya
eu le temps de cela fausse authenticité
mais il ya aussi nous qui accepte ou non
mais je pense que oui mais c'est sûr que
aussitôt que l'on réfléchit quand même
aux affaires compte il est mort
on peut dire que je relativement a tenté
mais à présent je vous dis pas ça serait
le mois authentique autant de 5% ça
m'appartient pas ça je le sais que ça
serait pas payé c'est que jamais fait
quoi on est toujours un peu dans le
mensonge a quelquefois fait que meiway
fait que j'imagine qu'ils ici qu'est ce
que ça change
au final être méchant mais ouais il ya
quelque chose là dedans qui est je
trouve ça dangereux dako liste mollahs a
dit me dit mensonges souvent un tiers
des mises en scène qui sont qui sont
fausses et utiliser le mot mensonge et
les mouvements sur le mode angers une
couple de fois dangereux mais je trouve
que on se doit de se poser ces questions
le parce que il ya comme une tendance
vers la superficialité qui qui est à mon
avis problématique pour pour tout le
monde qui tout le monde qui consomment
ce actuellement tout le monde qui va
s'en venir consommer simplement parce
que sa part de ralentir ça a pas l'air
de devenir plus véritable ça n'a pas
l'air d'avoir une tendance aussi que les
gens vont éventuellement se rendent
compte qu'ils peuvent être qu'ils
veulent pour vrai puis puis je trouve
que ces tirs la fameuse des droits mais
j'ai pas choisi qui qui suit mettons le
fait que de 10 culpabiliser de tes
prises de ce que tu montres de ce que tu
fais parce que sous prétexte que t'as
pas choisi ton following mettons je
trouve que c'est une façon facile
d'éviter le problème
je crois qu'il y en a un problème c'est
que c'est c'est l'offre hors faire
quelque chose en tant que société pour
régler ce qui n'est pas toujours très
clair le problème de ces mais moi je
pense que c'est un problème c'est un
problème psychique le tir pour ton à un
moment donné comme intégristes et puis
on le voyait nuit le tout le monde est
sur les antidépresseurs - les gens de ma
génération les plus jeunes
et crises d'angoissé crise de panique
c'est sion une espèce de pression le
jazz c'est pourquoi reims sedan parfait
descendu du ciel immaculé
mais ça arrive le tipi et nous il n'y a
pas de ceci tu réalises aussi quand
notre business et pas de fin quand tu es
maintenant comment la moins jouée sur ce
mont cho pleut je m'entends bien plus je
veux aller encore plus loin
l'édifice de croissance économique
infini le rappeler qu'à toile depuis
l'été comme tout le temps plus tout le
temps plus fait que tu aies jamais
heureux là dedans et qu'il ya un énorme
problème maintenant c'est un problème c
est un problème est un problème
personnel c'est un problème pour ton âme
c'est ça se voit peut-être pas mais je
pense qu'à la longue la force d'intégrer
ces codes là c'est difficile d'être là
dedans je pense est sûre je connais pas
toutes les citer maton et les
influenceurs le qui sont beaucoup dans
l'image qui se met même lille et hop je
connais pas mais j'ai l'impression que
d'offres est totalement heureux la dinde
aux postiers comme yes moi je lis les
autres l'ont peu d'offres est encore
dans la recherche de plus de plus de
plus vive un même même ceux et celles
qui sont les plus suivis doivent
regarder la vidéo
ben idir chrysler et oui c'est sûr même
eux qui tout le monde le regarde en
disant ça normal erreurs doivent
regarder du monde en disant ça normal
elle fait quelques pas de jeu patron je
peux pas te rendre puis tout le monde
veut se rendre mais je peux pas baissé
mais oui c'est un des gros mensonge
dingue c'est des gros mensonge permettez
moi j'ai vécu samedi j'ai une expo stade
et à faire quand même pire je me
rappelle une journée on a envie on vit
une journée horrible c'est comme vente à
mon sens chicane ce pas une bonne
journée mais on prend des photos au
travail et puis le soir pour une photo
puis les gens ils jaloux ce sera moi on
voit il était cool temps ça ferait pas
voulu être le stage n'est pas une bonne
journée mais la photo et n'est ce là la
sallaz paradisiaque du merveilleux petit
salaire de d'être cool s'est fait que
fait attention ça c'est clair
c'est super exemple c'est un fait qui
comme
des connexions ouais on met réalité be
le paraître meilleur coin de ma tête
quand même là dedans tu es moi je le
comprends aussi de faire comment mon
dieu que c'est simple un contrôle la
réalité est ici c'est moi qui peut
déterminer les paramètres comme vous le
savez pas que moi j'étais en dépression
le tchèque photo commun wawatie je veux
être toi merci tu veux être moi ça me
fait du bien parce que ça va vraiment
pas bien mais mewes et il ya une
puissance là bas une espèce de sortes de
contrôles que je peux comprendre que ça
devient du ctif c'est sûr que oui que
mettons un exemple complètement stupide
tu payes un voyage du pain voyage et un
voyage plein de la touriste peut-on
voyage c'est le ciment plateau pédant
mais si tu prends une photo de tes pieds
avec la plage très jaloux non merci
mais si tu regardes tes je pense chaque
génération est toujours un peu découragé
la génération qui suit les probablement
qui émigrent à part regarder mes parents
déjà et c'est que les jeunes n'ont rien
compris et à chaque génération comme si
on envoyait la fin du monde a rêvé où on
voyait comme à quel point les jeunes
sont non pas la porte mais n'ont pas je
suis trop galles mettant mes parents mes
grands parents qui n'étaient pas de
driver parce toujours plus le mais parra
marty tout ce qu'elle voulait c'est
s'occuper de ses enfants avec sa femme
et ses épis espèce de désir andré que
des générations ce genre de désireux
d'être le seul être le prochain steve
jobs et puis j'aurai révolutionner quoi
que ce soit ou attelé à voir le plus
d'abonnés ou aux fables tpiy toujours
plus toujours plus bien incapable
d'apprécier ce que te voir ouais c'est
pareil a pris après je sais ça ces
quelques défauts mais des fois quand tu
apprécies trop
qu'est-ce que topic qu'est ce que tu as
à petit pouvant table tu te rends pas
compte que c'est pour quand est ce que
ça peut être ça peut être un défaut si
ça peut être un problème mais ouais
moutons mais c'est seul narcissisme
aussi c'est vouloir amener soi-même
toujours plus loin puis mais ouais c'est
je trouve qu'on va leur espace et ces
qualités là justement l'espèce de la la
retenue la pudeur c'est le côté privé le
côté je veux c'est quand même c'est fou
de penser à ça mais s'est rendu pour moi
probablement des plus grandes qualités
de d'être capable d'apprécier quelque
chose puis de le garder pour toi mais
oui juste comme mais jerry le 7 à toi et
les gens de ton entourage que tu aimes
puis fait juste juste le vivent ces
prend le temps de le vivre ça vous
relance importante soit épicuriens de
ton propre potter arrête de vouloir le
protéger une maison
l'année passée pour illustrer exactement
ce que tu es un diriger j'ai vécu l'une
l'année passée j'ai couru le marathon de
québec feq ça fait deux ans que le court
mais l'année passée je le courrai puis
j'avais un partenariat avec new balance
grecque j'avais j'étais tenu sur
instagram de voir là dedans quand
j'allais courir de parler de new balance
de montrer des photos new balance
pendant le marathon puis après d'en
parler puis l'expérience des corps est
peut-être comme ça c'est que c'est que
je payais pour m'entraîner c'est quand
même là dessus mais là cette année
j'avais pas ce partenariat
puis quand j'allais au jim des fois je
montrais mungo recalt le juste parce que
ça m'intéresse de partager ça au monde
qui me suivent mais souvent le plus
souvent qu'autrement 9 fois sur 10 quand
j'allais au jim c'était juste mon moment
- il le marathon c'était j'en ai parlé
quelque peu mais sinon c'est je t'aime
mon moment - ben ouais c'est ça fait
toute la différence les stats watts et
les hôpitaux
je sais pas c'est quoi ta vie puis sa
main tournent tous nous on a tous nos
démons de tout notre appui d'été se sent
un peu un combo conçoit et met l'hôtel
au bout de soi même puis
être là dedans complètement avec sap a
participé quand même en personnel mais
mais ouais c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
valorise en société c'est la pudeur le
privé en juin pour toi - meetic comprend
aussi des fautes vous exprimer c'est
bien correct s'exprimer c'est ce que je
fais de ma vie en chine mais puis je
comprends cette compulsion là mais il ya
vraiment de quoi quand même deux à
cultiver ses traits culturels en fait je
pense qu'on a passées dans notre culture
sont les japonais sait pas si les
japonais sont forts oui mais son étang
sur son étang sur les technologies mais
je sais pas si on sent quand même été
probablement comme plus plus réservé
plus pudique il doit vraiment avoir de
photos de hache sur instagram leur fille
ouais ouais c'est la porte est close
c'est le ksar vole un peu c'est tout ça
c'est quel type ses défauts amman merci
beaucoup à un plaisir je terminais ouais
quoi un plaisir et ghost est vraiment
sympa c'est demain super belle
discussion pourrait on invite les gens à
aller écouter ton podcast
oui moi un plaisir à tourner un jeu
tournait encore avec du coeur au ventre
puis c'est mon pote cas sur toutes les
plateformes moineaux et comme vous
autres pièces félicitations pour votre
job les gars merci s'est dite inquiète
aussi
merci